la page culture de ce mercredi on reste
dans la culture malgré tout Aurélia même
si c'était des jeux vidéo auparavant là
on va s'intéresser à la poésie avec
votre invité Jacques Fournier vous êtes
amateur de jeux vidéo pas du tout vous
aviez l'air très intéressant pendant
créatifs
mais voilà on peut aimer le foot et la
poésie aussi c'est pas pour autant que
le foot est un produit culturel on va
parler unique on va parler uniquement
poésie pour l'instant et oui donc à
l'occasion donc de la sixième Biennale
de la poésie donc à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines donc qui est
organisé qui a démarré le 9 mars et qui
va durer tout le mois donc une trentaine
d'événements sont organisés
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
max c'est la sixième ça veut dire que
depuis
2003 la première édition voilà nous
donnons rendez-vous habituellement tout
au long de l'année déjà aux habitants de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines les environs
mais cet événement très particulier
pendant trois semaines trois semaines un
mois quasiment sur tout le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines sur les 7
communes puisqu'on investit je crois une
vingtaine de lieux avec nos 30 et
quelques manifestations qui seront
prioritairement des temps de rencontre
avec des comédiens des lecteurs et des
poètes puisqu'on a basé principalement
notre thématique outre pour être du
monde thématique habituelle de la
Biennale on a basé notre thématique sur
l'oralité qui est le thème du 15e
Printemps des Poètes nationales que l'on
investit que l'on intègre de notre
biennale alors donc première date
c'était samedi dernier donc des poètes
sont partis des comédiens voilà donc
sont partis à la rencontre des habitants
et nous avons notamment été filmés ces
rencontres à Élancourt au 7 Mares donc
on va regarder un micro-trottoir de ses
habitants et voir un petit peu ce qu'ils
en ont pensé on regarde
je trouve ça génial parce que comme
j'aime beaucoup la poésie
je trouve ça
enrichissant et
très
décontractant aussi je ne dis pas
beaucoup de poésie mais c'est bien c'est
une bonne initiative une initiative
menée sur quatre sites commerciaux de
l'agglomération cinquantinoise dans le
rôle des clameurs de rue ce samedi la
compagnie compte en banque qui a déjà
présenté un spectacle au prisme pour
attirer le passant dans leur filet de
mots ces poètes n'hésitent pas à suivre
le pas pressé des habitants d'autres se
montrent meilleur public
à la culture c'est bien ce qu'ils font
c'est vous avez récupéré aussi des
poèmes qu'on vous a donné nous allons
faire quoi je les envoyer en petite
chérie
alors quel était l'objectif de cette
démarche de laisser place au poème c'est
à dire mettre le poème dans l'espace
public ce qu'on essaye de faire depuis
11 ans qu'on fait depuis 11 ans avec la
Maison de la poésie des temps de
rencontre avec avec les habitants avec
les gens qui vivent sur place
c'est-à-dire aller les voir là où ils
sont on était au marché de Trappes le
matin au théâtre de au centre commercial
de Saint-Quentin des 7 mars et de Guy et
de Villaroy l'après-midi et dire aux
gens voilà la poésie c'est fait pour
vous donc demandez à des comédiens
amateurs dont on connaît la qualité du
travail de dire des textes ça pas
toujours été facile puisque c'est c'est
un c'est un c'est un métier c'est un
travail très difficile d'aller vers les
gens dans des dans des endroits assez
difficiles parce qu'il y a du bruit
parce qu'il y a du mouvement parce que
les gens toujours l'impression d'être
pressé et dire aux gens voilà ce qu'on
va vous proposer on vous le donne c'est
un cadeau qu'on vous fait on vous donne
un poème à entendre mais on vous le
donne aussi sur une carte postale on a
imprimé 4000 cartes postales 10 poèmes
différents de 10 poètes qui sont mis à
l'honneur pendant la biennale et on
donne la carte aux gens et on n'a pas
ramassé une seule carte postale par
terre c'est à dire que les gens partent
avec ça il la mettent dans leur poche il
la lise on a des surprises avec des gens
qui reviennent nous voir en nous disant
le quand on est toujours sur le marché
j'ai une carte mais j'en aimerais bien
en avoir une deuxième et parce que c'est
pas la même parce que j'ai de l'envoyer
comme disait le jeune homme tout à
l'heure je l'ai envoyé à ma chérie bah
oui on va c'est les garde postal c'est
fait pour être envoyé et on est heureux
nous quand les gens s'emparent de cela
s'empare du poème et un jour se dit ce
poème il est fait pour moi parce que je
n'y connaissais rien j'ai l'impression
de pas connaître la poésie nous on
montre aux gens que la poésie est fait
pour tout le monde c'est une manière
d'approprier de s'approprier le poème
complètement la parole de l'autre qui
est faite pour soi alors le lancement
officiel aura lieu le 18 donc à la
Maison de la poésie à 19h exactement et
donc comme vous le disait tout à l'heure
le thème cette année te tour de la
sonorité de l'oralité
pendant la Biennale
que des poèmes dit lu
murmuré chanter mais pas de spectacle au
sens propre du terme d'accord et pour ce
lancement
scène ouverte à la Maison de la Poésie
maison ouverte on va dire passer à
l'ouverture maison ouverte c'est-à-dire
que des poètes de la Biennale des
comédiens mais aussi des chanteurs de de
l'ensemble vocale de 50 ans en Yvelines
seront dans tous les bureaux dans toutes
les salles dans le hall de la Maison de
la poésie et diront des poèmes aux gens
qui passeront avec leur verre et leur
assiette de de cocktail à la main et il
y aura aussi le vernissage de
l'exposition de Annie Toussaint au dire
des connard exposition sonore une
vingtaine de poètes du monde qu'elle est
allée enregistrer lui disant des poèmes
dans leur langue en français et les gens
découvriront l'exposition à la Maison de
la Poésie pourront s'isoler sous le
casque rencontrer les poèmes par la voix
et découvrir que voilà les les poètes
sont des 10 heures et rentrer dans une
intimité alors qu'autour d'eux il y aura
peut-être un peu de bruit un peu de
brouha du passage et cette exposition
sera présentée jusque fin avril pourquoi
ce choix de ne pas faire de spectacle
c'est justement pour casser cette
barrière qui existe virtuelle on le fait
des spectacles on en fait on en fait on
en fait toute l'année on produit on
accueille tout au long de l'année et là
on s'est dit sur sur ce temps-là on va
faire quelque chose de différent la
venue des poètes des rencontres des
lectures mais ça on le fait aussi voilà
et puis c'était aussi la possibilité
pour nous de peut-être de plus mettre
l'accent sur le thème du printemps des
poètes c'est association qui a des
grosses difficultés financières
actuellement parce qu'un de ces
pourvoyeur pour ne pas le citer
l'éducation nationale refuse de lui
donner la subvention à laquelle il a le
droit et il va se retrouver dans une
difficulté qui va peut-être l'obliger à
mettre la clé sous la porte après 15 ans
d'activité voilà et nous ça ça nous
dérange énormément parce que le
printemps des potes c'est un partenaire
essentiel pour nous c'est une véritable
chambre déco de notre travail depuis 15
ans travail avec eux depuis 11 ans et et
c'était très important donc on a voulu
mettre l'accent dessus en disant voilà
il y a l'oralité bah très bien on s'en
parle de l'oralité on va faire que
pendant trois semaines sur un côté
militant sur cette édition
sur certaines dates justement
oui musique et musique et paroles aussi
puisque ce sera la comédienne et
chanteuse contralto Frédéric Wolf
Michaud que les habitués de la maison
connaissent bien c'est un projet qu'on
accompagne avec Frédéric depuis l'an
dernier le projet c'est elle demande à
un poète de lui donner deux noms de
poètes et elle monte un spectacle
lecture spectacle avec des textes de ces
trois auteurs là c'est Sophie Loizeau
pour être de Versailles que l'on connaît
bien aussi qui est une une habituée de
la maison qui vient de publier son
dernier ouvrage chez Flammarion et elle
a choisi Stéphane Mallarmé et Marina
vetaeva la poétrus et donc Frédéric Wolf
Michaud va s'emparer ses textes là et
créer un travail dont on ne sait ce
qu'il va être parce qu'elle va
travailler en plus avec un musicien de
jazz d'improvisation
Jérôme fluidiste d'improvisation de jazz
et elle aussi dans la voie dans
l'improvisation et ce qu'elle va nous
donner là voilà ça sera une surprise ça
sera pour moi je pense à un grand
plaisir de découverte alors autre date
musicale aussi donc le mardi 26 mars à
l'auditorium de la batterie donc à
Guyancourt en hommage à André Chedid
décédé en 2011 il y aura exactement ou
quasiment exactement deux ans qu'elle
sera décédée
50 qui lui rend
RA au massage
des textes de d'André Chedid mis en
musique par des poètes des musiciens
contemporains
André Chedid était la la grand-mère de M
la maman de Louis Chedid elle était
passionnée par la chanson aussi
puisqu'elle avait écrit des textes pour
son petit-fils et voilà on a tenu
accompagner cet hommage parce qu'en vrai
Chedid est une dame qui a lancé la
première Biennale de la poésie en 2003
elle avait accepté l'invitation et voilà
on c'est une dame qui
a 4G j'ai toujours énormément de respect
et parmi les différents hommages on peut
aussi citer celui du 30 mars hommage à
Aimé Césaire médiathèque de la verrière
des champs des poésies des danses
également ambiance festive toujours
voilà toute la journée notre hommage qui
sera qui sera rendu au cours de cette
biennale donc on parle de la médiathèque
on peut parler du coup des partenariats
que vous avez engagé comme d'habitude on
est je l'ai dit on est sur les sept
communes du territoire on est même
au-delà puisqu'on est à l'université à
la Sorbonne à Paris on est à Andrésy
aussi qui est appartenait de
poésieveline on prolon on sera on sera
on sera aux prises on sera au théâtre de
50 ans en Yvelines à la ferme de bel-eba
à la résidence de personnes âgées avec
Lucienne Deschamps je peux
donc vous parliez des cartes postales et
puis il y a ces affichettes dans les bus
donc avec bus ça aussi c'est un
partenariat habituel qu'on a créé avec
ce quibus c'est ses affiches à poèmes de
poèmes qui sont mis dans tous les bus de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pendant un
mois à peu près et là aussi ce qu'on
veut c'est que les gens en montant dans
le bus à n'importe quelle heure à
n'importe quel moment de la journée
lisse ce texte et puis se dire à un
moment tiens ça c'est pour moi
maintenant qu'ils viennent à la maison
de la poésie qui viennent nous voir sur
une autre manifestation qui qui nous
suivent qui nous accompagne qui nous
téléphone nous ambassent ça m'intéresse
etc c'est génial mais qui seulement qui
garde ça pour eux c'est aussi très fort
parce qu'il faut savoir que la poésie
c'est quand même l'appel à l'intime
c'est le la révélation de l'intime c'est
pas toujours évident de le dire on l'a
vu avec la difficulté de certaines
personnes à écouter les poèmes quand on
veut leur dire voilà maintenant s'ils
arrivent à pour en disant on a plus on a
choisi des textes qui sont très
accessibles la poésie est accessible de
communication c'est une vraie campagne
de communication et c'est là je crois la
quatrième année qu'on le fait avec ce
qui est bus est toujours un grand
plaisir de travailler avec eux alors on
va juste très rapidement vous pouvez
nous dire vraiment très rapidement
il y a un écrivain poète que vous aimez
particulièrement donc c'est Dominique
sans Pierrot que vous souhaitez un peu
mettre en avant qui sera là deux jours
le 20 le 20 mars sur la librairie
millefeuille qui est un partenaire aussi
habituel et à la librairie le pavé du
canal pour une rencontre pour parler de
son travail et il sera le 27 à la
médiathèque Jacques Brel de Magny le
matin pour un atelier d'écriture ouvert
aux familles et l'après-midi pour une
lecture accompagnée par le contrebasse
hystérique prala Dominique sempiro était
là l'an dernier il avait animé un
merveilleux atelier d'écriture il était
venu présenter petite mère à la ferme de
Bel et bac était un spectacle créé à
partir d'un de ces textes mais il
s'empiro c'est un scénariste ça commence
aujourd'hui de Tavernier de Taverny
c'est aussi un merveilleux écrivain
d'une immense sensibilité d'une immense
humanité et qu'on a envie de défendre
jusqu'à présent il sera présent sur le
territoire pendant un bon bout de temps
parce qu'après il enchaînera avec une
résidence avec la ferme de Bel et bas et
on aura l'occasion de le revoir très
certainement à la rentrée sur positive
et d'en reparler peut-être même de le
voir sur ce plateau d'ailleurs pourquoi
pas pour venir en parler merci Jacques
Fournier merci à vous trouverez nous
parler de cette permission de la
Biennale avant de se plonger dans le
moyen-âge parce qu'on va parler
Moyen-Âge ensuite au cours de cette
chronique culture les sorties ciné vos
réactions à la sortie des premières
projections du matin comme chaque
mercredi avec Élodie moine j'ai beaucoup
aimé c'était très bien et pour toute la
famille je pense
c'est une histoire assez
et les couples de 40 ans qui se
remettent complètement en question donc
voilà non c'est bien moi j'ai trouvé que
c'était un film avec beaucoup d'humour
enfin moi j'ai vraiment beaucoup aimé
c'était
vraiment un bon film c'était
vous voyez les couples alors une fois
ils se disputaient une fois il se
remettait ensemble et c'est vraiment
très sympa c'était un très très beau
film très émouvant voilà on a beaucoup
aimé trop que c'était bien joué à
l'histoire elle était belle en fait
parce que vraiment ici et beaucoup
intéressé après
un peu difficile disons que j'ai pas
retrouvé l'artiste ça représentait
maintenant du point de vue
film scène j'ai trouvé ça très joli
c'était un très beau film que ça fait
longtemps que j'ai pas vu de film en
noir et blanc voilà j'ai beaucoup
apprécié
et après le cinéma le moyen-âge donc on
change d'univers alors le Moyen-âge et
du côté de la commanderie des Templiers
à Élancourt dans le cadre d'une visite
découverte à deux voies on va voir de
quoi il s'agit
les vieilles pierres de la commanderie
des Templiers ont des choses à nous
raconter une visite découverte entre
patrimoine et art contemporain nous est
proposé le premier dimanche de chaque
mois dans le cadre du label Ville d'Art
et d'Histoire il y a la moitié de la
visite qui est vraiment sur l'histoire
et l'architecture des lieux et puis dans
le même temps on propose aux gens de
découvrir l'exposition actuelle du site
donc l'exposition d'art contemporain
puisque aujourd'hui c'est le cœur du
projet de la commanderie des Templiers
donc en ce moment c'est une exposition
de dessin ça change régulièrement et
comme ça les gens peuvent même revenir
plusieurs fois avec leurs amis et eux
voir une exposition différente à chaque
fois sur les chemins de Saint-Jacques de
Compostelle ce lieu emblématique fondé
au 12e siècle par les moines soldats de
l'Ordre du Temple a connu de multiples
affectations utilisées au départ pour
l'accueil des pèlerins puis converti en
exploitation agricole la Commanderie est
restaurée et ouverte au public dans les
années 70
une deuxième vague de restauration en
2008 et 2012 en fait aujourd'hui un
centre culturel et historique à vocation
polyvalente l'art contemporain est à
l'honneur cette année dans le bâtiment
des gardes qui accueille les expositions
temporelles l'originalité de la visite à
devoir offre ainsi au public une mise en
parallèle entre l'histoire de ce lieu de
patrimoine et l'art contemporain qui est
exposé on n'avait jamais eu de parcours
historiques sur la Commanderie on a
l'habitude de voir des sculptures
modernes ici des artistes des artistes
contemporains et ça nous choque pas de
le mélange des deux la chapelle dernier
témoin médiéval de la région et les
expositions sont à découvrir tous les
premiers dimanches du mois
et un atelier pour enfants donc toujours
sur la thématique Moyen-Âge dans le
cadre de la confection de blasons et
cette fois-ci au château de la Madeleine
à Chevreuse
atelier de dessin et de découpage pas
vraiment le parc naturel de la Haute
Vallée de Chevreuse a proposé pour les
plus jeunes un atelier ludique de
fabrication de blasons au château de la
Madeleine au temps du Moyen-âge les
raldique permettait de s'identifier
durant les combats couleur métaux forme
chaque élément du blason a une
signification les enfants ont dessiné
leur propre emblème un moyen pour eux de
se représenter
et en argent mon bulazon avec des épées
voilà pour cette thématique moyen-âge on
termine la chronique culture par un
petit agenda et oui donc une date à
retenir ce dimanche donc afin de
préparer la Saint-Patrick donc il y a
lieu dimanche je vous propose un
rendez-vous pour 3h d'initiation aux
danses celtiques aux danses irlandaise
et donc ça se situe au centre Aimé
Césaire donc à La Verrière donc de 15 à
18h ce dimanche
à Saint-Patrick merci Aurélien d'être
venu pour cette page culture sur ce
plateau on retrouve la semaine prochaine
on va continuer à parler un petit peu
Moyen-Âge avec la suite de cette édition
par l'éducation